Wow
ladies and gentlemen two people come in
two meals are swapped but only one can
win who will win in this week's episode
of meals from Thailand versus Philomena
representing Thailand we have aria from
the Philippines welcome Jenna today
we're gonna be swapping comfort foods
I'm gonna be swapping with you my
all-time favorite comfort food lumpia
Shanghai so lumpia Shanghai is a type of
spring roll my mom makes it with pork
and there's like a bunch of vegetables
mixed into the pork and our celery
there's water chestnuts and it really
gives it that crunch I can eat so many
so that's why I think it's like a
comfort food because because I eat so
much it looks great I love anything
fried I'm very close it is all fried
what is in the sauce this is
sweet-and-sour sauce
so this is actually the sauce that I
commonly ate it with I'm very excited
for that if there is a difference from
an egg roll what makes it unique I guess
commonly
I've seen a lot of egg rolls like a
little bit bigger and chunkier but this
one is very bite-sized and smaller and I
think that's what makes it stand out you
can really eat so many and not feel that
guilty unless you eat like me and eat
like thousands my comfort food is from
my time in Thailand mango and sticky
rice it's got a popular dish you've seen
a lot in Thai restaurants here but of
course back in Thailand
it's obviously also a staple there
because you know it combines elements
such as mango which we have growing you
know in the in the jungles there Damaris
we go I'm not sure has mango which we
love in Southeast Asia
it's got sticky rice sticky rice is a
staple in Thai and Lao cuisine but it's
also can be used as a dessert compliment
because here it's soaked in condensed
coconut milk since there's a fresh bit
of fruit there you feel like it's
healthy this is not healthy at all but
you know what sometimes you guys savor
what life has to give you and I'm
excited for you to try it it's been
quite interesting because yours is
savory - if anything this actually make
a good combination for both yeah you
know what we could actually eat both of
them together that is the joy of food
brings people together yeah really
it was a competition a competition yes
so I'm gonna have to defend my lumpia I
think it's gonna win let me tell you
something all right this is a dish that
is entire restaurants all around the
world because people want this
they crave this they need this high
restaurants will not serve this if the
mango isn't perfectly sweet so that
statement is all I have to say I think
mine is gonna win because it look at it
it's like you have everything in this
bite-sized lumpia shanghai you have the
meat and you have veggies you have the
wrapper and it's great for any meal or
even breakfast I've sometimes had this
for breakfast
you find it everywhere in Filipino
parties so it's a very common staple Wow
oh it's most delightful oh I really
smell the mango oh it looks fantastic it
looks perfectly fried what's the rap
need out of it's made out of my mom's
love she makes it the best like all
Filipino say this but my mom makes the
best lumpia I really like these these
are dangerous mm-hmm I feel like I
should alot of these right now I feel
like right now you'll probably want more
probably like oh good well the flavor of
the Olympia itself I can taste the pork
I can see how the water chestnut kind of
has like I don't think if you didn't
mention water chestnut I wouldn't have
placed what that flavor is coming from
but I guess that's where it's coming
from and the dough I know you said meant
to be usually crispy but I kinda like
the texture right now and then of course
the this is a sweet and sour sauce just
complements it perfectly I love this
yeah just right off the bat there's this
like almost creamy consistency I think
from the coconut milk and then when you
bite into it's just like a burst of like
mango condensed milk flavor
I absolutely would order this yeah I
would order this again I I like my meat
so usually I'd like to have meat and
rice but the mango it meets a mango I
love the texture of mangoes I personally
love mangoes um but I do like my meat
which is why I do this Julia is very
dangerous yeah like I'm on my third
already I'll have one more bite but yes
I do I do want my I'm happy to keep this
how do you say hello the most that
like Spanish because of colonization
right well yes that's how you would
greet someone and the guy love the
language of the Philippines how do you
say hello in Thai yeah us this 20 car
and then I say somebody cop I don't want
a budget so any cop
Sawadee kha Sawadee kha which means like
how are you now I don't wanna butcher
that I love this but you know my true
love is Mookie up getting that bite it
yeah I had savoury yeah now you get the
sweet now I have to decide which one's
better big cuts up I'm kind of right now
being seduced by the lumpia but maybe
the taste of the mango sticky rice will
take me back yeah Chiang Mai Thailand
mmm it's like a tempting mistress I
don't know the wife takes you back home
you know I don't know do I do I wanted
hop ship are things going well with my
wife or am I ready for something new
am I in my midlife crisis I wish I was
eating this like a little bit crispier
because my mom's lumpia is best when
it's fresh out of like frying but I
think in terms of flavor it's still
pretty similar I like that it still has
the pork and the water chestnuts
my mom will pack it with celery and
carrots and water chestnuts and just
like combine it all together so you
still get a little bit of nutrition but
you still fry it anyway so I think the
flavor is still like similar this is a
good dish the mango is a little more
sour than I would have liked I think
it's better when it's sweeter and then
they were very generous with the amount
of coconut milk because of that I think
it's a little wetter than I would prefer
yeah I was gonna say it's like very very
wet and I look very sticky yeah normally
it's not quite so wet but that said it
still has the hits the same flavor so
I'm enjoying it but I will say the
mistress dangerous one yeah this is
actually a very very tough decision for
me I'm gonna take a couple more bites of
this and then I think I'll have my
decision made
when I first saw the lumpia I thought it
looked great but I wasn't sure if the
taste was gonna hold up to to the
appearance but it was fantastic I
certainly will be looking for more
Olympia in my future so I did enjoy the
mango sticky rice it's very sweet
and I I do love my sweets but I'm
definitely more of a savory person which
is why I think lumpias still is the
winner for me but yeah I definitely will
still look out for the mango sticky rice
if I'm out at a Thai restaurant but you
know lupillo still has my heart you know
up until this very moment now I'm still
battling it's just gonna be a gut
decision in the moment well beyond
lumpia was fantastic I gotta say it one
I would have that every day mango sticky
rice feels like something I could maybe
have once a week if that you know it's
very rich but the lumpia I can see how
that's just a staple in gatherings like
you said well aren't well deserved you
say congratulations in Tagalog oh shoot
how do you say for some reason I can
only think of thank you which is
salaamed selamat
[Music]